What if we have more data available?
Can we determine if the additional data
will result in a better prediction?
We also have some data that shows
the contract value per client against
the average number of tickets.
Using Google Sheets, we can plot
the data with a linear equation and
a value for r squared.
In this case, we have a linear equation
with an r squared value of 0.785.
This new data is similar to the original
data when comparing values of r squared.
But what if we could use both sets of
data to develop a better predictor?
Let's introduce multiple linear
regression, which builds upon the simple
linear regression by using more data to
strengthen the correlation coefficient